Prof: You're going to
get more numbers today.
I know you--how many love
numbers?
You can't live without numbers.
What did I tell you was the
traditional, before modern
times, death rate?
A number you should keep,
or birth rate,
it's the same--about per 1,000?
About 40 to 50 per 1,000 is the
birth and death rate at a life
expectancy of 20 years,
that means 1/20th of the people
die every year and so you need
50 out of 1,000 births 1/20th of
your people to be births;
so births and deaths,
in what we call primitive
times,
which might mean up to the
Napoleonic Revolution,
almost is 40 to 50 births and
40 to 50 deaths a year.
Now here is modern times.
We're starting in 1950 in all
of these graphs and coming in
the period of the popular--
main--beginning births of the
population explosion 1950 to
1990 in all these cases.
And here are the various parts
of the world and you'll notice
that this is the death--
I'm sorry the birth rate is 50,
birth rate is 43 or something
42,43, 45,45.
That 1950 the birth rate is at
approximately its level for
centuries way back.
We know that not too much
before this time since
population was not growing until
some--
a little bit before this time
that the death rate must have
been the same,
so the death rate was also 40
to 50 people.
Look what happened.
By 1950 the death rate is
already down to half of its
traditional level,
even in Sub-Saharan Africa it's
almost reduced to half;
in Central America,
the Caribbean,
less than half;
South America less than half;
China about half;
South Asia about half;
Southeast Asia about half.
In most of the world by the
1950s the birthrate was still
extremely high,
but the death rate had come
down to half of what it had
always been.
What was going on is that these
countries were almost all still
under colonial rule with the
exception of South America,
which might be a reason why
it's even better.
And, among all their faults,
the colonialists did institute
basic sanitation,
basic public health,
basic public order and they
stopped a lot of the warfare
between communities.
They imposed a lot of violence
upon the people but that was
apparently much less then the
violence that local communities
imposed upon each other in the
pre-colonial era,
so the death rate was down by
the 1950s.
Sometime in 50s,
around 1950,
the birth rate started coming
down in all those countries,
and even though the birthrate
starts at these very,
very high levels they come down
almost everywhere with of course
the exception being Sub-Saharan
Africa,
and you've read about why that
is and I keep saying that almost
everything we say,
SubSaharan Africa is an
exception to the rate.
Even though the death rate was
down,
the birth rate didn't change
much, but in every other part of
the developing regions of the
world,
the birth rate and the death
rate came down approximately in
parallel with each other.
Of course the difference
between that birth and death
rate is population increase -
and this is the heyday of the
population explosion.
Remember this is per 1,000 so
it's a percent kind of a number,
so as the population grows the
number of people represented by
this percent cap grows and
grows,
and grows, and so this explains
the graph I showed you last
time,
or two times ago.
Starting again in 1950 to 1990,
the number of people added each
year just keeps growing,
with one blip and you'll see
later in the course,
I've shown you that blip
before, but we'll discuss what
that blip is.
The data for the individual
regions of the world and this
all fits together,
makes sense.
Now we've been through the
European population story,
and again we saw that,
not always but mostly,
the death rate fell first and
then the birth rate fell and
Europe went through a population
explosion.
To say this story the way I've
been telling you,
no differences,
that the third world is just
going through exactly what
Europe went through,
but it isn't true.
Let's compare two of the
fertility transitions.
This is Sweden and this is
Mexico, and you'll notice that
Sweden has birth and death kind
of hanging around until maybe
here,
until 1860s,
and that's just what the
Princeton Project found out that
the really serious decline
happened somewhere in this 1870
region,
and then the death rate
declines rather continuously on
through the time,
and the birth rate declines.
This starts around 1870.
Mexico's decrease starts around
1970.
So between what we now call the
developing countries or the
third world countries,
about 100 year difference
between when Europe started its
transition and when the
developing countries started
their transition.
Now 100 years may seem a lot to
you,
but in the course of human
history,
since these numbers had been
going on forever,
100 years is a very,
very short time.
Another difference you should
note is--Hang on,
I just fixed this.
Usually that's all that
required I hope.
Nope.
Anybody have a laser pointer by
any miracle?
All right, we're going to have
a little bit of trouble today
but I think you can figure
things out.
Notice that the levels of
everything there are lower in
Sweden,
that Sweden starts and the
European countries generally
start at a lower level of births
and a lower level of deaths,
so they were already,
by the time that their serious
transition starts,
they're already quite a ways
down compared to where Mexico
starts.
Notice that the deaths and the
births are much higher in Mexico
than in Europe.
Now those are important,
but notice the gradualness of
the decline here.
That Sweden had a long time to
adjust to these changes,
whereas, look at the drop in
the death rate in Mexico.
Boom!
Basically all of a sudden and
then give it a generation,
look at the drop in the birth
rate.
That's the most amazing thing,
how rapidly things change in
the developing world,
compared to the way it changed
in Europe.
Because of this rapidity of
this decline and a natural delay
here,
whereas in Sweden that might be
the delay,
the delay means because of the
rapidity of the decline,
that the difference now between
births and deaths is this huge
amount compared to a much
smaller amount here.
Europe never had to cope with
the rate of increase,
the number of people added
every year,
the percentage of the
population, never had to cope
with anything like what the
currently developing countries
had and that's a result of the
rapid drop.
The other thing to note,
of course,
is that by this time,
the births and the deaths in
Sweden are essentially equal,
and Sweden's population is not
growing anymore and that as you
heard from Dr. Teitelbaum's
lecture,
is characteristic of Europe as
a whole,
as well as Japan,
and a lot of the East Asian
countries.
A cartoon of this which has--a
lot right about and one big
thing wrong with it,
is that here's the rich
countries, they start--
this is the pop--rate of
increase of population growth,
that they start earlier,
he starts it quite early in
France,
and 100 years later--in this
graph it's called 'poor
countries' start.
The peak, the rise is slow,
the fall is slow,
the rise is fast,
the fall is fast,
the peak is much lower here.
The peak is about 1%.
The maximum rate of growth that
Europe ever experienced was 1%,
whereas, for poor countries,
the average was 2.5% and some
were up at 3%.
So, enormously greater stress
on the countries that went
through this very,
very fast.
Why did this happen?
Why is it so much faster in
developing countries?
We say that as each country,
as it gets into their
transition phase later,
everything happens faster.
It's quite a robust phenomenon.
Every few years,
you say, oh man China or some
country,
Korea, Taiwan,
had the fastest decline ever
and then a few years later some
new countries enter in and their
decline is even faster.
One of the main reasons is that
contraceptives were invented
around here.
The pill, the diaphragm,
kind of all that--
well some of them went way back
here but the modern method,
the really modern methods were
all like the pill in around the
1960s.
This is a graph showing that
the developing countries are
using contraception,
so here is contraceptive
prevalence,
the percent of women and
childbearing ages that use
contraception,
and it ranges from very little,
less than 10% to like 70%.
The U.S.
is in the 60% to 70% range.
Notice that the fertility,
the total fertility rate,
if the country's not using
contraception,
very high fertility rate,
as they use more and more
contraception their fertility
rate goes on.
The mechanism in the developing
countries is use of
contraception and mostly modern
contraception.
Whereas, when Europe went
through its transition,
they didn't have hardly any
contraception.
Some condoms were just
beginning to come in but none of
the modern chemical methods or
the better kinds of barrier
methods.
The story is kind of--that,
why the developing countries
are faster is that the science
is already there,
the medical stuff is there,
the death rate comes down
because again Europe developed
the medical know how and then it
just got transferred very
rapidly: vaccines,
vitamins, viruses,
all of those were discovered
before the transition there.
Just as important as the
knowledge was an attitude toward
civil government and civil
society that it is the
responsibility of governments to
take care of the health of their
people.
That's not a given.
Most countries,
through most of history,
the government was rapacious
and their idea was to get as
much taxes from the peasants as
possible.
The peasants were sort of like
non-humans and use those taxes
to have an army and go try to
get--enlarge their territories.
The idea of civil government,
where the government is for the
people is a fairly modern idea
and one of the basic things that
governments try to do is public
health.
Then of course--on the
technology,
the contraceptives I've
mentioned, the means of mass
communication,
I'll show you a slide later
that change in behavior is
triggered a lot by what you see
on television and what you see
on the radio,
what you see in newspapers.
As in chimpanzees,
we're a very social species,
and we're always looking to see
what's acceptable,
what kind of behavior is
acceptable.
Gossip, maybe I mentioned this,
that most of what humans say to
each other is gossip and the
function of gossip is to find
what are the limits of
acceptable behavior,
so the mass media is extremely
important in like telling people
in this case that two children
is the proper way of families.
They see American television,
American movies,
or Japanese,
and what do they see?
Rich people with two children,
whereas as they previously
believed that in order to be
rich in some sense you have to
have eight children,
so the media are very important
in changing perceptions.
Also, for a very long time,
maybe not now,
the West had--cachet--was
considered the future,
the modernity,
the West was very respected and
loved around the world and so
the use--
the small family norm was a
characteristic of the Western,
a lot of people tried to become
like the West,
there was that cachet.
Of course family planning
programs, the west had a long
experience with family planning
programs.
You've read some of the
Margaret Sanger stuff from
America,
the Marie Stopes stuff from
England,
where people are struggling
with these things and finally
come out the other end and
decide to gain control of their
fertility.
In a sense, both medically and
culturally,
Westerners were the guinea pigs
for this fertility transition
and then once it was,
in some sense,
perfected and finished in the
West,
it was sort of transferred
wholesale to the newly
developing countries.
Now another thing about the
fertility transition is that not
only is it more intense
demographically with all the
statistics that we can gather,
but it's also more intense
emotionally.
As you're for sure well aware
by now in this course,
there's enormously strong
social norms about sex and
reproduction,
and if those norms are about to
change it attacks one of the
most important foundations of a
culture and there's--
that does not happen without a
lot of conflict within the
culture.
In the West,
although there's a lot of
discussion about this,
the idea of individualism,
that people individually go out
and do what's good for them,
they make choices based on
their own desires.
There's kind of a long history
of that and it was sort of
formalized by Adam Smith in
economics saying,
that if everybody went out and
tried to get as rich as possible
it would be wonderful for
everybody.
In most of the developing
countries they have a more
communal kind of attitude,
whereas, often if you speak to
older,
say Chinese,
or Indians--the smallest unit
of desire which they speak of is
the family;
very hard to get them to think
of what THEY want.
It's the family,
or village, or some larger
entity.
When you start changing norms,
the norms in non-Western
societies or pre-modern western
societies are very much stronger
in control of the people.
People have less latitude to go
and do their own thing;
they're under social--much more
social control.
Of course all of these things
multiply--square these things,
quadruple them,
if you're talking about sex.
One of the readings,
I don't know if you're going to
do it tonight or you did it
already, about the Palestinian
woman who was killed.
Did you--was that--not in your
reading yet.
What it is, that a Palestinian
woman was suspected of some
infidelity,
no hard evidence for it,
and her little brother killed
her after searching for her for
many years.
The idea of giving you that
article is it's a tear jerker,
but it gives you an idea of the
emotionality of the--
strength with which the older
social norms are held and
someone who appears on the
surface,
even mildly,
to violate it,
can get killed.
A Jordanian woman has just come
out with a book 2003,
Honor Lost,
and she talked about her best
friend and this is what
triggered her,
apparently, to write the book.
This woman, her friend,
had been seen in public walking
with a man who was not a
relative.
Now not doing anything bad but
right there in public,
so you know nothing was going
on on the streets and this being
seen alone--
being seen on the streets with
a man who was not a relative was
such a stain on the family's
honor that the woman's father
stabbed her 12 times in the
chest and then stood over the
body to make sure that she was
dead before calling an
ambulance.
Imagine the strength of the
cultural norms that allows a
brother to kill a sister,
or a father to kill his
daughter.
In this last case,
this woman who the father
killed her,
the family was not poor and was
not Muslim,
even though it's in Jordan but
they were middle class and Roman
Catholic.
So that means--almost nobody in
these cultures escapes the
cultural norms even though
Catholics in Jordan are a very
small minority as is the middle
class in Jordan.
They obey the same rules of the
culture as everyone else.
The author of that book claims
that this happens to thousands
of women, that there's thousands
of women dying in honor--so
called honor killings.
Now, of course,
it's not restricted to the
Middle East,
you will read a little bit
later a reading for India where
a woman is raped by her
father-in-law and her own father
insists on killing her.
That's from India.
You have to contrast this with,
not all cultures are like this,
so contrast this very tight
strict norm about women's--
not giving women any
possibility for going beyond the
norm,
compare it with the Na of China
which I think you've already
read,
where everything is totally
free, or the Japanese,
the story of the Suye Mura
women;
have you read that yet?
Again, there's a huge amount of
sexual freedom.
So it isn't that all cultures
have the same cultural norms,
but they all do have cultural
norms and violation of those
cultural norms will be punished.
Another thing is that,
in the different stream,
the Western and Eastern
fertility transition,
is that the economic
constraints, the level of
poverty in the third world is
much worse than it was in Europe
at the time of its transition.
Everything is more difficult
when you're poor and you live in
a poor country with poorly
developed government,
everything is more difficult.
In your reading packet is a one
page collection of headlines
from Tanzania and you just see
all the problems that Tanzania
is going through in a period
when their fertility is high and
maybe beginning to start falling
down.
We have some understanding of
the many ways in which
statistically,
except by magnitude,
the fertility of the
demographic transition in the
countries that have entered
since 1960 looks very different
from those that entered it in
1860.
Quantitatively also,
when you go through a period of
population growth,
the question is well how much
did your population grow
altogether between the beginning
of the transition which we've
had the beginning in Europe and
the end in Europe,
as your text says something
like 1870 to 1930 and Europe
grew by about a factor of four,
so the population quadrupled.
This was the time when the
population of the developing
countries was staying constant.
But developing countries--India
actually,
as far as we can predict,
is having one of the smallest
between four and five,
so they're sort of at the
maximum for Europe,
no country in Europe was more
than four and India,
one of the lowest countries for
the developing world,
would be somewhere between four
and five so we expect.
Mexico will have grown by a
factor of seven to ten times;
Kenya by more than fifteen
times, so here is again,
countries that started the
transition poor,
they're still moderately poor,
Mexico is doing better but
certainly Kenya is not and India
is doing somewhat better.
And now they have to cope with
five, six, seven,
eight, nine,
ten times as much population.
Because of these multipliers,
the fraction of people in the
different parts of the world
goes first one way and then the
other way.
Before the mortality
transition, Europeans
represented about 18% of the
world's population.
At its maximum,
when Europe had the maximum,
Europe and European people in
America,
Australia, New Zealand and so
forth,
but European stock people their
fraction--
the European fraction of the
world population doubled,
more than doubled actually
from--about doubled from 18% to
35% so they--
Europe was
undergoing--Europeans were
undergoing a huge population
thing.
Now--by 1995 because Europe's
population growth is over,
European people's are over,
and the developing countries
population growth is starting
it's back to where it started
and it's back to about 18%.
Now--that's 1995 and we've had
already 13 years of population
growth continuing in the
developing countries and it's
continuing and getting more and
more.
The relative percentage of
people in,
what's now called the
developing world versus the
European world,
is going now to be so high in
the developing countries that
it's way beyond anything that
was historically the case,
except maybe when humans
started moving out of Africa and
into the Middle East and into
Europe.
This may not stabilize--so far
there is no sign that European
population,
almost all of the European
populations now have fertility
rates below 2.1 and so they are
going--
if they continue with that of
course they eventually disappear
altogether,
and the idea that there's going
to be some stabilization at some
ratio of say rich and poor
countries is dependent on
fertility coming up in developed
countries and we don't have any
reason to expect that.
This is an important factor
because,
if part of the developing
countries coming out of poverty,
is aid from the West and that's
again--
everything is debatable in this
course,
how much help aid does.
It actually--there's no
question about that in some
cases it's tremendously helpful.
That if there's nobody left in
the developed countries to give
the aid,
then one of the props which
helps developing countries come
up will have disappeared.
We've gone through the
quantities of the transition,
but we have compared the
demographic transition of
developing countries with
European countries,
but we haven't compared it to
anything else.
The world population,
as I say, is growing something
like 70 to 80 million people a
year.
The question is,
if we imagine some sort of a
landing for this,
what kinds of things are going
to stop this population
explosion?
There's bad things and there's
good things;
bad possibilities and good
possibilities.
The bad possibilities and have
been known--
have been thought about for a
long time is 1) famine,
that people could start
starving, disease,
AIDS, people are always talking
about Aids balancing the
population explosion or war.
I'm going to give you some idea
of the magnitude of these
factors.
Famine, one way that famine
operates is,
some country has a big drought
and they go through a short
period of terrible famine,
but that's not the main thing.
People all over world and
especially children are
malnourished and malnourished
leads to disease.
It's very hard to get these
statistics and to gather these
statistics, and it depends on
who you're talking too.
I was teaching in a health
course and we sort of did serial
lectures and Michelle Barry,
a professor of international
infectious diseases,
gave the lecture before mine,
so I went to her lecture to see
the lay of the land,
and she was describing millions
of deaths from various diseases.
The medical students,
this was to medical students,
had no clue and they were just
absolutely shocked at the
magnitude of what's going on,
especially in developing
countries.
She was listing,
maybe you know,
Aids is about--back then it was
two million a year,
it might be three million and
coming down;
Malaria, tuberculosis from the
one to two million deaths a year
kind of thing;
diarrhea in children, etc.
These are--the massive killers
in the world.
Next week I came on and said,
you know what,
there's x millions of deaths
from malnutrition and they were
shocked because it was an even
bigger number then what
Dr. Barry had given.
I said, you know what,
they're the same deaths you
heard about last week.
The thing is something like--I
don't remember the number,
something like if you take a
skin test for tuberculosis,
something like a third to a
half of us have been exposed to
the TB bug so that we have
antibodies against it.
We basically in some sense,
in a small sense,
have had TB.
If you go to India more people
have had it but the fraction
that actually come down and get
sick is much,
much higher.
Why?
Malnutrition.
That all of the diseases,
if you're malnourished your
immune system and your other
body systems can't fight the
bug,
so you actually get sick and
will often die.
There's a big discussion of
when you see a death to say TB,
is that death caused by the
tuberculosis bacillus or is that
death caused by malnutrition?
The World Health Organization
and a lot of other groups are
now saying that the about half
the deaths from all these things
are really at base caused by
malnutrition,
that at the level of infection
that the people are exposed to,
you should see so many deaths
but you actually see twice that
many deaths because people are
hungry.
The numbers from the Food and
Agriculture Organization of the
United Nations are--
is that 25,000 people die every
day,
like today, 25,000 people will
die from starvation or
malnutrition.
That's a huge number.
That's nine million deaths a
year and so I calculated it out,
during the course of this
lecture 1,300 people will die of
starvation or malnutrition.
It's really very serious.
Most of the death--yeah?
Student:  How many
people are born during this
lecture?
Prof: What?
Student:  How many
people will be born during this
lecture?
Prof: Also a very large
number, more than the deaths.
We've seen that the--you can
calculate it yourself that the
birthrate is something like
three times,
two and a half times the death
rate,
but that's not just that--you
can sort of double the total
number of deaths will be
something a little more than
double the deaths from
malnutrition,
so a lot.
The population is still growing
I'll bet, as you've seen,
because we do have a lot more
births than deaths,
and I showed you that data
before.
Malnutrition is the leading
cause of death in children in
developing countries,
and the numbers you read are
all over the place,
and one number that I pulled
out is 13 million child deaths a
year and I've seen lower than
that.
The World Bank in the--it's
millennium goals,
you know the big millennium
goal thing what the whole world
is supposed to go to,
says again, that half the
deaths of children under five
are due to malnutrition and--
there's altogether,
for all reasons,
there's 13 million child deaths
a year and you get numbers from
different studies saying
anywhere between a third and a
half of these deaths are due to
malnutrition.
What does malnutrition look
like?
You may have seen--this is
kwashiorkor, how many of you
have heard of that?
It's a very prevalent kind of
thing.
Do I have a slide?
You go to a village in poor
places and you see these
distended bellies?
This is everywhere and actually
we don't even--in --there's a
tremendously prevalent thing,
we don't actually know the
cause of it.
The old story was that it's a
protein deficiency disease and
protein makes albumin and
albumin holds water into the
blood and the tissues,
and when you can't hold water,
it sort of floods into your
tissues and spreads out,
but now there's a lot of other
theories and we just don't know
really what's the basic cause of
kwashiorkor.
It is malnutrition.
That's--there's no question
about it, but exactly what in
the diet is missing is not
totally clear.
Here's another kind of shocking
thing, now I'm going to give you
some shocking pictures and
tearjerkers but it's important
to see.
This you've seen.
This is an American missionary
or aid worker,
I don't know which and that's
her baby and that's this baby
and they're both six months old
in Africa.
Another thing that happens is
that population--
when population grows the
people who are strongest take
the best land and they push out
people that are less strong,
or have less population or are
less violent or whatever reason,
or less technologically
advanced, they push them into
marginal land like deserts.
This is the site in Mali of
what used to be one of the
largest lakes in Africa and then
it goes through periodic
climatic things;
it dries out every so often.
In some sense,
people should not be living
there because you know it's
going to--
it goes every so often through
droughts,
but they have no choice because
stronger people's in the past
have pushed them into these
desert kind of regions,
one of the results of
population explosion.
I've told you,
in Europe, where the extra
farmers had to go up hillsides
and into less profitable land,
so there they are in this very
arid region and in normal years
they can survive,
but then comes a drought and
this kind of thing happens and
the result,
of course--this is a boy who is
I think nine years old or
something,
he's 13 pounds and almost
impossible to keep that boy
alive.
Here's one of the really
saddening pictures that--
in the political discourse
about population,
and fertility,
and family planning in America
there's a lot about motherhood,
how wonderful motherhood is --
everything but you have to see--
well I didn't show that.
I've got--I put in the wrong
picture which is maybe good for
you.
Now you've seen a lot of these
pictures.
The organizations,
they want you to give money
show a lot of them and one of
the discussion items about these
kind of pictures is that they
make people in poor countries
seem sort of helpless and that's
not true.
The amount of stuff that people
in these countries are doing to
try to help themselves is
enormous,
they can be very strong and
very smart people,
but their resources are very
limited what they work with.
The bottom line of this little
bit is that given the number of
deaths that we understand to be
from malnutrition and given the
number of population increase,
if the solution is to be solved
by famine,
if the balancing of births and
deaths is going to be a famine
situation,
the starvation rate must
increase by a factor of eight,
plus or minus.
The next thing is disease;
disease is the second of our
triplet of horrible solutions.
In 2008 it killed about three
million people,
up from two million,
and this is clearly--apparently
the peak.
Everyone apparently--Because of
the retrovirals and various
other public health measures,
the number is supposed to go
down.
The numbers are already
changing.
At the end of 2007,
the UN got a whole bunch of
better data from certain
countries and they had to--
they lowered the number of
people they thought to be
infected with the AIDS virus by
6.3 million.
So something like 33 million
people infected with AIDS,
and presumably they will all
die at some point,
although the retrovirals can
keep them alive a long time.
Notice that 33 million is less
than half of one year's
population growth from AIDS.
It's--the way it works out
demographically is here is
somewhat older data at the--
from the peak of the AIDS
epidemic,
this is the impact in
Sub-Saharan Africa with and
without AIDS,
so the gray--the purple is the
way the population -was modeled
to increase without AIDS,
as if there was no AIDS,
and then with AIDS,
AIDS kills these people
basically, prevents these
births,
you still have an enormous
population increase for
Sub-Saharan Africa which is the
worst affected place.
This is one of the worst
scenarios --they did a worst
case scenario run which they
sort of imagined things to be
about as bad as they could get.
This thing, when you do it for
a whole--most of a continent
hides a lot of difference;
this is Uganda,
which had a very intelligent
response to AIDS and here,
with AIDS there will be this
much, and without AIDS there
would have been this much,
but population keeps growing.
In any case,
in South Africa,
which is about the worst really
badly hit place you do see that
population growth without AIDS
would be this and they're
actually expecting population
growth to come down as a result
of AIDS.
In some countries,
it has an important demographic
effect, but for Sub-Saharan
Africa, as a whole,
not an enormous effect.
In the rest of world,
where, at least so far,
the numbers are much smaller,
a minor effect.
It can easily get lost in the
statistical noise that we don't
know how many people are on
earth,
we don't know exactly how fast
the population is growing and
AIDS can be within that
statistical noise.
From a demographic point of
view, AIDS as a killer,
is significant.
Let me show you there's another
thing that kills 1.6 million
people more than half of the
AIDS number.
You'll never guess what that is?
It's this, it's smoke from
cooking fires,
that in the developing
countries, in the poor
countries,
this is the way people cook and
the smoke fills the room,
gets into their lungs,
and they get all kinds of
diseases extra and the estimates
of that is 1.6 million deaths;
comparable to tuberculosis and
malaria and somewhat less than
AIDS.
They have a solution to this
and it's a stove that
keeps--that you don't get these
kind of smoke with.
And those cost $10 each and
they'll cut out a number of
deaths equivalent to half of the
AIDS deaths.
One of the things--if you're
interested in understanding the
magnitude of the problems of the
world,
one of the things you just have
to pay attention is the
magnitude of the problem and the
magnitude of any solution.
When there's an almost sure
thing of $10 available and
retrovirals cost an awful lot
more, which kind of person are
you going to try to save?
The person that can be saved by
$10 or the person that needs
$1,000 to be saved if you have
limited kinds of money.
From a demographic point of
view the problem with--
almost worse than the total
number of deaths because
malaria's been killing people
for a long time,
and TB and these are all
horrible situations,
of course every death is a
horrible sort of thing,
but AIDS kills people in the
prime of their life and that's--
this is what we call hollowing
out of the Age structure so
there's children who are
dependent,
there's adults who work and
there's old people who are
dependent.
If you kill off your working
people that leaves the kids with
no one to take care of them,
no one to provide economically
for them,
that leaves the old people with
no one to take care of them.
The direct deaths from AIDS
itself is one horrible thing,
but what they do to taking care
of everybody else in the
population multiples that effect
by a lot,
and as of 2001 the last
statistics that I could find,
there's about 12 million
children that have been orphaned
in Africa due to AIDS.
That is--we do a lot of work in
the political refugees,
that's triple the number of
political refugees that there
are in Africa.
We've done famine,
disease, and wars is the last
set of numbers and you hear it
at cocktail parties that some
war,
whatever the current war is,
will balance births and deaths.
The worst we've had is the atom
bombs,
and I don't know if you know
what the numbers on the atom
bombs are,
but the Hiroshima bomb killed
75,000 people,
the Nagasaki bomb killed 25,000
people.
That's 100,000 people dead in
two quick flashes.
The population on earth grows
by approximately 200,000 a day.
What that means is that,
if we can imagine,
and all these are imaginary,
if we imagine that some wars
are going to balance births and
deaths on earth that means that
every day you have to blow up
two Nagasaki bombs and two
Hiroshima bombs,
killing that equivalent number
of people just to keep even.
That doesn't reduce population,
that just keeps population
flat.
The idea of giving you all
these horrible numbers is just
to give you an idea of the
magnitude of this issue and that
it's of course absolutely
unthinkable that one sort of
continues to just let this
situation go rampantly until one
of these negative kind of
disasters happens.
There's got to be a solution.
We have to figure it out in
some way.
So far in the last lecture or
so, I've obviously been what we
call apocalyptic.
The world is coming to an end
due to population explosion,
but there's a famous saying to
the opposite,
which is that if something
can't go on forever,
it won't.
I think that has a large chance
of happening and I've described
some of this already to you in
our last lecture and I'm going
to talk more about it right now.
Consider these two interviews,
one is an interview very much
like one of the ones in your
readings, it's from Mali in
1983, Sitan.
This is a woman who's heard
about the contraceptive pill but
has not used it.
Interviewer:
"Sitan,
how many children more would
you like to have?"
"That is for God to
decide."
Interviewer:
"You yourself,
how many more children would
you like--
how many children would you
like to have in your whole
life?"
"I don't know the number.
It's when God stops my
births."
Interviewer:
"How many boys and how
many girls would you like to
have?"
"It's God that gives me
children.
Since it is God that gives or
not, you cannot make a choice
about your children."
You've read some of these,
this is a different country,
a different time,
but this is a not uncommon sort
of attitude where people,
women especially,
just can't--it's not within
their calculus of conscious
choice.
Now in Bangladesh,
which is again,
both of these countries are
Muslim, Bangladesh is more
conservative religiously.
The poverty getting better now,
but it was about the same,
so there's the socioeconomic
indicators for the two countries
are about the same,
but the government in
Bangladesh was very different
and the government,
from very early on,
decided that they would make
family planning available in the
country and the international
groups then came on board and
said,
okay, we will help you.
This is now another interview
with an 18 year old girl named
Shamiran and she is just
learning that there is such a
thing as birth control.
The reason she knows about it
is that,
and you'll read about--you're
going to read about the family
planning program and the results
in Bangladesh,
is that as I said Bangladesh is
a very conservative Muslim
country.
So, women generally are not
allowed out of the house to get
medical service for instance.
Just to go out and talk to
women's meetings where these
things get discussed.
No. They can't do that.
The family planning program in
Bangladesh,
the government program and the
private program,
hired high class women from
that community,
who themselves were using
family planning and thought it
was good and sent them into the
houses of poor women who
couldn't come out.
This is kind of like if
Muhammad--the mountain won't
come to Muhammad,
Muhammad will go to the
mountain.
The people in the village all
know about this woman who,
Mukti Ma, that was her name,
and she's considered a health
worker and she actually gave her
aunt,
her aunt was an acceptor and
Mukti Ma was giving--
came by regularly to give her
aunt pills and the girls knew
about it.
But they didn't really
understand it and so they went
and asked the aunt,
the girl Shamiran,
and the aunt refused to tell
her anything because again the
social conservatism,
that these matters will be
explained to her only when she
is married and she's not to know
anything about this now.
What did the kid do?
Like every kid everywhere else
in the world she goes to school
and talks with her friends,
and they all pick little bits
of information or misinformation
and pull it together from the
other girls.
Some of them apparently knew of
Mukti Ma, some of them didn't
know about her.
I'm sorry I said everyone in
the village knows,
apparently they didn't,
but since this girl's aunt was
getting pills from Mukti Ma she
knew about it,
but every one of her
schoolmates was interested.
One girl said,
"I would like to work as
she does,"
she Mukti Ma.
"Look at her,
she wears her sari so nicely
and goes to different
neighborhoods.
My sister told me she earns a
good amount of money."
Others said,
"but my father and
grandmother says she's not a
good lady."
Shamiran said,
"Grandmothers and fathers
are always behind the times,
they do not want to let girls
go to school,
I don't want to consider their
opinions,
I like Mukti Ma's work and I
will have pills to control
births."
Some girls said,
"Yes, I think we should
have this medicine so we will
not have so many problems with
so many children.
With few children,
we'll be able to keep our saris
clean and nice,"
Then everybody laughed together
and that apparently ended that
interview.
This is an older generation
versus a younger generation and
there's an interest of the
girls,
as they self perceive it,
and the interest of the older
generation,
as they are trying to impose it
on the younger generation.
It's a very clear kind of a
conflict situation.
The girls see having many
children as just causing a lot
of problems and what the girls
are interested in is not having
a lot of children as--
which was terribly important to
their--
certainly their grandparents
and probably their parents.
They want to have nice clean
saris and look nice.
They want to be able to earn
money and go around to different
neighborhoods.
The older generation is trying
to keep them out of school,
keep this information away from
them, and keep them in the mold
previously.
The girls in that society are
pretty much powerless because
even though the age at marriage
has risen,
Shamiran's already 18,
which traditionally is terribly
old for a girl to be unmarried.
She'll eventually get married,
moved in with her husband,
and the husband will also be a
teenager probably and will have
not much say --
the husband's mother will be
the arbiter of medical things,
reproductive things,
so that both the son and the
daughter-in-law will be under
the control primarily of the
mother-in-law and so it's the
mother-in-law's opinions that
count,
the mother-in-law's attitude
toward reproduction that counts.
Very often we,
in the west,
say that--
the problem is all with men,
the macho men force women into
having children and some of that
is certainly true and sometimes
in Latin America a fair amount
of that can be true,
but in Asia it's very often the
mother-in-law.
Wherever you see that the young
girl--
they get married young,
the husband and wife are both
young,
they move into the husband's
house which is the grandparents
house,
then the boy will be under
control of his mother and the
new wife will be perhaps almost
a slave to that mother.
You have many,
many instances where both the
boy--the husband and the young
girl wife do not want to have
children but they don't have any
choice.
In matters of reproduction it's
mother-in-laws who are the
dominant transmitters of culture
in the thing--in the world.
I showed you in the data at the
beginning of last lecture that
the Shamirans of the earth,
who are not so enamored of
having a lot of children,
have taken over from the
Sitan's of the earth,
who will have as many as
they're going to have.
The data was very strong that
women in the developing
countries don't want all the
children that they're currently
having.
You've seen new data and you've
seen old data from that.
I showed you Bolivia new data
you could--
I can--you can come up to my
office and see the Demographic
& Health Surveys and pick a
country and it's pretty much all
the same.
With the exceptions of
Sub-Saharan Africa is somewhat
exception and some of the Arab
countries,
not the Muslim countries,
many Muslim countries have
really reduced their fertility
but Arab countries are going
through a non-standard
situation.
This information has
been--we've had this since about
the 1960s.
We've had it for about a half a
century, knowledge that women in
the developing world don't
really want the children that
they're having.
In the 1960s they started with
a survey called KAP,
knowledge, attitude,
practice.
Knowledge: did you know about
contraception?
Attitude: do you want it,
what do you think about it?
Practice: are you actually
using it?
Then from 1972 to 1982 there
were surveys called The World
Fertility Survey which were
improved from the KAP surveys
and they reached 62 countries
with 350,000 women interviewed,
and then from 1985 they've been
coming along with these
Demographic &
Health Surveys,
which are more or less
standardized across the world,
and from which the data I gave
you came.
If you listen to the verbal
report of these women,
they say they don't want these
children.
The question--you have to
always question--scientists
always question everything,
okay they say that,
but how much oomph!
is behind it?
It could be an interviewer
comes in,
obviously a very modern person,
you know that modern people
sort of think that the modern
way is to have fewer children,
so you may very well answer
them in that way so you can
never be sure of these surveys.
You always have to look at what
are people actually doing and
there are various ways that you
can find out if this a real--
a desire backed by behavior.
One of the things is well how
permanent--of those women that
choose some sort of family
planning method,
how permanent is it?
How good is it?
It turns out that basically
everywhere in the world
sterilization is the dominant
choice for family planning.
In Brazil, for instance,
by the late 1980s and their
fertility has come down from
then,
40% of married women using
contraception in fact chose to
be sterilized over all the other
methods.
Now you might think that this
was the poorest women who chose
this, that they were kind of
desperate.
Maybe they were influenced by
family planning workers to just
get it over with,
and I've heard polemical
arguments saying that,
Oh, these sterilization things
are because that was what was
pushed upon them by some family
planning program'.
In fact, statistics are very
clear that the higher the income
level of the woman,
the greater likelihood that she
was to choose sterilization.
One of these--have any of you
seen this film about testing the
birth control pill in Puerto
Rico called La Operacion?
It's sort of a far feminist
thing but very--shown very
frequently.
One of the places that the
birth control pill,
invented in America,
was tested was in Puerto Rico.
It shows a lot of people,
they're talking in Spanish,
but there's a narrator speaking
in English which most everybody
can understand,
and the narrator is saying how
terrible everything is and that
these women weren't told what
was going on.
What you see when the narrator
is speaking is an older woman
who wasn't eligible to be a
subject in the test,
at night climbing into the
window at the basement of the
hospital to get the birth
control pill and the narrator
says nothing about that,
but they're showing this to you.
Have you seen it?
I saw--had sort of a hand up.
In the U.S.,
among affluent,
educated women that nobody is
presumably pushing around 13.8
million--
women use tubal ligation,
a female form of sterilization
as their method of birth control
and less than that 13.2 million
were using the birth control
pill.
In the United States,
like in almost every other
country, sterilization is the
chosen means.
I think that's one indicator
that when people say they want
reduced fertility they really
mean it.
Sometimes family
planning--contraception is not
available and then people can
get into very desperate
situations.
An American maternity nurse
went to Lusaka in Zambia and
this is the University teaching
hospital in Zambia.
So, most of these developed
countries will have a capital
city and they have one high
class hospital that'll usually
be attached to a university and
that's demanded by the upper
class of that country,
the political elite,
the economical elite demand
good modern medical services,
it'll be one hospital there.
You can look at the public
health budget for these
countries and a very
disproportionate amount of it
will go to this one hospital.
This University teaching
hospital in Lusaka is the high
level hospital in Zambia.
This nurse went into the
maternity ward;
she was a maternity nurse,
expecting to see a lot of women
having children.
Instead this is what--this is
her report.
"Ten women with botched
abortions were lying on nine
beds.
Five others were sprawled on
the concrete floors of the
hallways.
A few more were in the hall--on
the floor outside the entrance.
There were no blankets or
covers.
Most wait 12 hours for
treatment from a physician.
The 'average' woman ends up
overnight on the floor;
she receives no food or water.
The women were aborting on the
floors or on their way to the
single toilet at the end of the
long hall;
30% of the patients complete
their abortions on the concrete
floor with no medical care.
All we can do is clean it
up."
That's what the head nurse
there said, that all we can do
is clean it up.
This is not isolated to this
one hospital.
You can go anywhere in the
underdeveloped world and at
least half the beds in maternity
wards are taken up with botched
abortions.
What goes on is,
in most of Africa,
and a lot of the world,
abortion is illegal,
so doctors can't do it,
so they go to what they call
bush doctors,
some very poorly trained
midwife or someone who just says
they'll do it,
and they have this operation
and usually something is put up,
a stick or coat hanger or
something up the uterus and they
try to scrape out the fetus.
But, in fact,
they often puncture the uterus
which allows infection to get
into the main body cavity,
and then after a few days
they're getting very sick from
the infection which is now
systemic because it's inside the
body,
plus the wound doesn't heal
because of the infection so
there's constant bleeding and
they can bleed out.
Huge death rates,
we're going to talk about
abortion later and I'll give you
some of these numbers,
but huge death rates.
Important point for this course
is that probably all of these
women know of someone else who
has died from one of these--
shall we call them
unprofessional abortions.
Yet, when they get pregnant,
their desire not to have that
extra child is so strong that
they will themselves choose to
undergo this very,
very serious operation with a
very high threat of death.
That's one of the things that
the Planned Parent Federation in
its international efforts like
what you saw is trying to cure.
They had one project to go to
Kenya to train local private
doctors who somewhat escape the
law in family planning and
abortion services.
The local doctors had been
turning away abortion clients
because they did not know where
to refer them,
so that means they got some
unskilled practitioner.
One physician told the project
director that he had turned away
a young girl only to find her in
a hospital a few days later
after she had procured an
illegal abortion.
The girl died.
The private doctor said that he
had since then lived with a
great deal of guilt.
He is happy now that he can
provide treatment using a very
safe procedure.
In between that they've
legalized things to some degree
in Kenya.
It's not only the third world
in which this takes place.
In Bulgaria,
sometime back under the Soviet
system, 57% of pregnancies ended
in abortion.
You'll hear during the abortion
lecture in the United States,
there's one abortion for every
three live births,
and something like 40 to 50
million abortions worldwide and
about half of these are illegal
and illegal means very unsafe.
A woman dies,
it's about every three minutes
from a botched--one of these
illegal abortions.
I think with these stories and
the large numbers that are
attached to them,
I mean any woman in that
situation that has an abortion,
she does not want that child
and when you say there's 50
million of them worldwide that
means that the demand for
control of fertility is very,
very high.
You'll read the Brazilian
solution to this which is a
modern form of infanticide.
I don't know if you read yet,
the Death Without
Weeping,
it's in your reading packet
where mothers who know that they
can't raise a child just leave
the child to die and they say
that 'God can take better care
of it then I can' and they just
let the child die.
This is not to say that--So,
what has happened in the world
is that fertility has come down
drastically and I've showed you
that in previous graphs where
the fertility is coming down,
and in the peak period in
Bolivia during the peak--
the number doubled from about
12% to 25% of people using a
modern method.
Ecuador, 50% of the women are
using a modern mechanism.
Tunisia, 60% and Iran is one of
the really interesting cases.
Iran had this very conservative
government and they were against
family planning and all this,
and then they had the war with
Iraq.
Iraq invaded,
with U.S.
help, and huge numbers of
people died,
including a lot of kids,
so afterwards their young
people were depleted but once
those kids--
they recovered a little bit
from that,
the government realized what
was happening and decided on a
family planning program.
This is an Iranian woman
packing condoms.
We have this image of places
like Iran as being so backwards
and conservative and everything,
but they have,
in fact, now one of the best
family planning programs in the
world,
and the UN a few years ago
awarded it their top--
best program in the world and
their fertility rate is now at
replacement level.
Fertility is coming down almost
everywhere, with again
Sub-Saharan Africa and some of
the Arab countries as a counter
example.
Birth rates not only--Birth
rates fell;
Thailand 50% in 12 years;
Columbia 40% in 14 years,
this is at the peak.
Indonesia 48% in 20 years;
Morocco 31% in 12 years;
Turkey 21% in ten years;
Brazil 60% in 25 years;
Mexico 30% in just six years;
Botswana 26%;
Zimbabwe 18%;
Kenya 35%, I mean everywhere
that you look the actual
fertility is coming down,
so people are using
contraception and using it
efficiently and the world birth
rate has come down quite
significantly.
None of this is to minimize
that people in developing
countries are caught in a bind,
that you all have heard all
kinds of reasons why they might
want to have a lot of children
and one is extra farm labor.
One is support for children in
old age, a major kind of
problem.
One their religion might demand
it.
Two cultural reasons,
various ancestor worship
reasons.
In India you have to have a son
to light the funeral pyre,
no son you don't go into the
afterworld properly.
We discussed some of this with
respect to Africa.
Status reasons,
you have more children you have
more prestige for both the man
and the woman,
there's macho reasons to prove
your fertility and the list goes
on and on.
The reasons they may not use
birth control are many,
one of which is family planning
services can be very primitive.
It's not a great slide but it's
an old bus in India with a red
cross on it and this is the
family planning clinic in this
part of India at that time.
People were supposed to go on
this bus and have some operation
that they didn't understand done
to them,
sterilization or IUD insertion
or something,
and you know you wouldn't be
exactly very anxious to get on
to that bus.
Another thing that I mentioned
last time with respect to
Veena's lecture,
that the worry about medical
complications is one of the most
major reasons why women either
don't use contraception at all,
or start it and then stop using
it.
What does this mean in a
pre-medical country where they
don't have really modern medical
ideas.
You take the pill,
you're scared of it.
Anything that happens to you,
you get a tummy ache,
you fall and break your leg,
anything that happens to you
what do you blame?
You blame the pill.
So here is a culture without
much medicine,
a low standard of living;
they're getting sick a lot.
People in developing countries
are not generally very healthy
and they get sick and they don't
know what it was caused by.
You probably read already about
The Evil Eye.
Did you read the Egyptian--the
Kul Khaal yet?
The Evil Eye is the reason.
If you've taken the pill you
know that's changing your body
in some way,
and you're afraid of it,
you get sick with anything,
it's the pill was the reason
for it and then you tell all
your friends that and everybody
in the community learns that
such and such got some problem
because of the pill so they're
very much afraid to use the
pill.
On an on, there's a big
conflict, big contestation,
the media, I think this is in
Morocco,
this is a cave,
this is the desert around here,
they're in a cave and what
they're watching is a TV show.
I was in Morocco in the far
desert and you see these little
villages of just a few mud
houses and they all had solar
arrays and they all had
television,
so media is passing on very
strongly.
On the other side of the
equation is all kinds of reasons
that they don't use it or that
they do use it.
It's a very much in
contestation.
In the West,
especially activists,
liberal people,
people in the Forestry School
believe that we shouldn't
support family planning programs
because it's politically
contentious.
Why is it politically
contentious?
Because people on the right are
opposed to it for religious or
moral reasons,
people on the more or less
left, and these are
characterizations right and
left.
We can't impose;
we 'great white Westerners'
can't impose our values on our
'poor little yellow and brown
cousins'.
It's utter nonsense and it's
patronizing because the people
in these developing countries
have spoken very clearly when
they add up all these pluses and
minuses.
That's their choice,
and as I've showed data--
I've hit you over the head with
data showing you that when
people in the developing
countries themselves add up the
data,
they want to be protected by
contraception.
I think that we,
in the West,
ought to take that very
seriously,
and starting with intellectuals
who should know better,
but since people don't give
courses like this and people--
even environmentalists and all
kinds of others,
just don't pay any attention to
human population because it's
politically untouchable.
The major organizations,
the environmental organizations
won't touch it because they do
fundraising and the public
opinion is that--
it's a horrible thing to push
family planning on developing
countries.
I guess that is where we will
end today.
See you--yes one more this week
before vacation.